Elizabeth is with us in Kansas City hi
Elizabeth how are you I'm good how are
you
better than I deserve what's up well I
kind of in a complicated situation I
recently became a single mom I have a
few kids and I do have money but I don't
know what to do with it because I am in
a weird life situation okay so you
recently became a so you went through a
divorce yes it's almost finalized okay
all right and how much money will you
have I will have between 40 and 50
thousand not much okay
that'll be gone about 20 minutes how
many kids have you got I have three okay
so what do you do for living I am living
yeah I am living with my parents and
they're letting us with them for free so
I don't have to pay for any housing
expenses right now that's a good
short-term plan I'm glad there was a
safety net to catch you but that's not a
long-term plan what are you gonna do for
a living I don't know I homeschool my
kids and so I don't wanna have to go
back to work full-time I do I do have a
decent income potential I could probably
make between forty to sixty thousand
dollars a year if I went to work
full-time but I don't want to leave my
kids all day every day I'm sorry I don't
want you to either but you have to take
care of your life and your kids and I
don't know of another way for you to do
that where you stay at home full-time as
a full-time mom nobody pays you for that
right I do have a little bit of money
that comes in every month that will pay
for all of our living expenses so it
would pay for car payments they're not
car payments but on car insurance and
groceries and just like living expenses
like that well it's on tomorrow I have
if there's a little bit that comes in
from a subsidy that I get and Social
Security okay that amounts to how much
about 1,200 why are you getting Social
Security it's like
well it's like I say that for one of my
kids it's like survivor synthesis oh I
thought you said you went to a divorce
yes I did it
was there a father on one of the other
children that passed away yeah okay all
right that makes you okay because you
don't get survivors benefit for a
divorce
struggling okay alright so you got a
little bit but obviously so here's the
thing this is all real fresh isn't it
yeah I mean the divorce isn't final you
just moved in with your mom the other
day right yeah yeah II okay I don't want
to be the one that tells you this but
your life has changed right you're in a
really tough situation and I don't see
an alternative to you going to work for
the next five or ten years how old are
your children they are 15 and 13 and 10
okay and so eight years from today I
don't think you want to sit down and
look at someone say we've been living on
$1,200 a month right I know I don't
think that works so where does income
come from if it's not you going back
into the workplace
yeah I mean I could like I could serve
you know a few nights a week and I can
probably bring in like a few hundred
dollars a week doing that I just I know
like I know Dave Ramsey stuff because
I've done it for years but I just I feel
like doc like I don't know where to go
right now I I wish your life hadn't
changed I wish you could have had the
dream of you being at home with them
and I'm glad you did have the time that
you had with them and we can grieve
together the horrible thing you've been
through that's left you here but I am
afraid that as your older brother I'm
going to tell you you're going to have
to get a job
is I don't think you want to raise these
kids serving at night and basically
living at the poverty level yeah well I
know I mean I cuz I know I you know I
listen to people doing their debt-free
screams and so now I'm just worried
about your family surviving around to be
a waitress at night and live on twelve
hundred dollars a month when you have
the potential to go into the marketplace
and make 60 grand and live at the
poverty level instead I just don't think
that's wise for you or those kids you
called me so I'm duty bound to tell you
that and I but I know what's going on
it's part of your heartbreak in this
horrible mess you've gone through and I
don't want to be the one adding I don't
throw salt on that wound you know you're
already dealing with enough of turmoil
but I'm just not going to participate in
for your own good I'm not gonna
participate in in a suggestion that
allows you to stay in denial about the
fact that this has all happened it's
happened it's sad it's heartbreaking and
I'm so sorry but you're I'm afraid
you're gonna be working unless we missed
some numbers in our discussion here I
mean if he's gonna pay you $5,000 a
month child support then okay we can
talk about it you can make it on that
but I'm hearing 1,200 bucks a month and
you're waitressing and you've got
teenagers at home I think they can go to
school and you can work during the day
and lots of people do that and they
won't be damaged with that lots of moms
work outside the home single and
otherwise mine did and I live through it
and never really skipped a beat honestly
so you know I got to tell you I know I
know that's not what you want but you
didn't want any of this and it's still
there you got to do it hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]